don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
hey baby hey baby hey girl say
girl say
hey baby hey baby hey
hey
baby
what's up babe hey babe we said hey baby
didn't i know but i like saying hey
because sometime because obviously you
know we let the fans know we've been
egging this on but we have legally
changed the podcast name to hey baby hey
baby wanted to do hey baby oh hey
no we'll do that
that doesn't count that's on the patreon
um i don't know about these pillows
though babe these pillows are dirty
they're most likely dirty where are we
where are we we're at the lyric you
could have been here but you're playing
in b more son we're in baltimore where
edgar allan poe died yeah we're
backstage and we are at the lyric
theater and we're what you've been to
before yes with the jokes a couple times
in the pastoru yeah very nice happy to
be back how were the last two times or
three times however long i don't know i
mean i i i uh you know how were they i
mean i'm sure they're all wonderful
wonderful the theater the theater is
gorgeous i don't know if you go it's
gorgeous and it's any and it's an opera
house it's our house we got 2 000 out
there i mean listen when you got two
thousand peeps coming out in the middle
of a pandy in baltimore things are good
yeah you know what i'm gonna hit him
with we're in the opera house i'm gonna
hit him with a full setup tonight see do
you understand what you missed
do yourself a favor right now go get
tickets october 29th to durham even if
you're not even re i don't care if you
live in new zealand get quarantined for
14 days and go to dortmund because he's
going to sing the opera there too right
big new zealand contingent in durham we
want to see well i don't give a [ __ ]
i'll sing opera anywhere
out opera house is where it's going to
be born that's where it's going to be
yeah but so but but will you sing well
let me ask you a question so this is an
opera house this is a lyric opera so
you're going to do opera but performing
on center what are you going to perform
i might juggle uh either bowling pins
swords or swords nice one of those by
the way whatever i feel comfortable with
come that time by the way your haircut
is shockingly good whoa
really honestly short-haired sound is
not for me anymore i like i like sally
sally bangs yeah yeah he did he did it
really good yesterday i can never
recreate what he does he uses a blow
dryer um he uses old product i can't
shout out max i don't know shout out
matt comes right to the house men's best
haircut i go to him why not yeah union
union have in williamsburg but then i do
this and it's my version but it don't
look as good i don't know the body and
bounce i come out of his thing i look
like i'm in a freaking l'oreal
commercial he's a he's a good looking
guy yeah shout out russians
i don't know if he's rushing speaking of
russians
on staten island today
i saw it was actually a taiwanese
restaurant so nothing to do with russia
but you know one in the same but
taiwanese a taiwanese restaurant what
are from thailand no no it's from
thailand not taiwan oh because that's
two different things a thai thai
restaurant a thai restaurant not a
taiwanese restaurant yeah not a
taiwanese thai would have been like
winis and you would have said no no land
land are we talking when these are when
you say thai are you talking winnies or
land yeah i'm talking land if i'm from
taiwan
what do i call myself taiwanese
taiwanese oh my god thailand people have
it so much easier yeah i'm thai i'm not
yeah i'm not i'm not i'm not thailand
i'm a jack talk thai jack talk very very
well
so i'm i'm i'm walking i'm driving i'm
sorry down far stephanie shout out for
us i love forest avenue um shout out
walking i'm walking here yeah
dustin hoffman dustin hoffman midnight
cowboy
great movie um
um i witnessed for the first time ever
in my life an act of robbery happened in
front of me before the police came like
i saw the entire thing on staten island
on staten island
five hours ago you're being anointed
into the island um post taste i'm here
yeah so we're go i'm driving yeah i'm
driving down i just came from the
mustard seed cafe shout out shout out to
pumpkin coffee and the banana bread from
uh mustard seed cafe amazing i'm driving
back and i see a man uh a thai a thai
man coming out of a
thai restaurant
who is a worker there with an ikea bag
the ones that you told me to move with
those blue eyes
just yeah blue bags which i didn't do
and i really regretted i was thinking
about you almost the whole move saying i
needed the bags yeah but
so he's walking with those bags and then
out of nowhere three other asian men i'm
not going to say that they were from
thai because i don't know i'm just
heavily assuming the man walking out of
the thailand restaurant was thai but the
other men could have been taiwanese they
could have been taiwanese yeah i don't
know it's how could you tell i can't
tell i have no idea so they were they i
saw three men come running and sprint
one of them kicked the man with the ikea
bag in the back sal i'm not lying to you
twenty thousand dollars in cash flew
into the air he the man rolled over like
a cartoon like rolled over barrel rolled
legs over his head money flying into the
air the the three guys came behind
grabbed as much money as they could and
starts sprinting down the street the man
is bleeding out of his head with that a
a suburban a black suburban comes from
across the road slams on the brakes two
men get out of the back scoop up as much
money as they can get in jet off i swear
to god there was maybe
three 100 bills left when it was done so
i think i witnessed like an actual
maybe mafia organized crime robbery did
the three initial men take money yes or
there's beat him and left no no they
didn't even beat him they just kicked
him he barrel rolled legs over the head
he he barreled like
money flying everywhere they scooped up
as much money and they didn't hit him
again what kind of a kick was this like
like like a flying ninja kick are you
serious he was airborne he was like he
was like
i've never seen i was and it was one of
those times where i wasn't texting i was
looking at my phone i just was look it
was almost as if god said this is you
need to get out and help him
so did you have the kids i didn't have
the kids i was by myself but but but
i
really really really i was waiting i was
at i was at um
the car wash uh a couple of minutes
before i'll tell you about that too but
i had gotten from the mushy's cafe in
avocado brownie and the woman said there
that you really need to eat them warm
i swear
like you yeah i'm really sorry but i got
the avocado brownie yeah it's supposed
to eat it warm so i had to get it home
your money's gone i had to get it home
from my to my family and that's kind of
what i felt not only was the avocado
brownie still a little warm and i really
need to get it home to my family because
they really need to try it it's so good
shout out mustard seed cafe um um i i
saw multiple people taking out their
phones to what i presume call 9-1-1 in
retrospect they could have just been
filming it sure but i thought they were
going to call 9-1-1 and also i there was
no if i was on the way of traffic
passing him i would have pulled over and
stopped i literally could not stop i
felt if i stopped and and and put my car
in parking call 9-1-1 now i'm impeding a
police investigation because the police
would have taken the cops longer to get
there there was genuinely nothing i
could do this guy had he was bleeding
from his eye with an empty ikea bag with
all his cash gone the ikea bag had the
money in it yeah there was loose money
in a non-zipable bag they must have
known they might what are you doing it
must be you see him feels like an inside
job from what i gave him
and just things i've heard in my life
because he's coming out with the cash
they know he's coming out with the kids
100
maybe he's doing like a drop or
something like he's taking the cash
she's going to the bank or whatever they
came at that moment and the car was
waiting 100 percent waiting on that fool
waiting on that four it was great it was
i was actually like a little shaken up
like that
i was almost like i may need another
brand i'd love if you like got out of
the car
he threw and parked he got out to go
walk to him and he's there bleeding
hunched over it a little bit and he's
like
where'd you get
go back he got the out y'all he got warm
you got it trust me
you need the brownie i'll be all right
i'll be all right people are calling
people
you got to hit that avocado brownie
mustard seed go back go back yeah
because
this couch is uh like three feet shorter
so i'm like turn like yeah and you're
right here and i could i could smell
your breath it smells good you always
have fresh breath really i think so i
hope i am fresh no you're fresh um
because because this this is a real
introduction to stalin because ten
minutes before that i was at the car
wash and this is and i sent i sent you a
voice note of this but i'll repeat it on
the podcast car wash very nice guy real
like italian
kind of gangster guy tattoos tattoos on
his neck i pull up into the car wash he
goes which one you want from the board
because you can get the silver of course
platinum or the gold i picked the
platinum which gives me interior
exterior and shampoos the masks crazy
platinums i need the plants so platinum
seeds
so i said
i'll take the platinum he goes it's a
good choice and then i said yeah would
you be able to get this putty on the
back of my car seat for my kids he goes
let me take a look he goes nope he goes
this party ain't gonna come out he goes
there's only two things in my experience
that never come out no matter how hard
you try that's putty and blood and i was
like
okay okay and then about 10 minutes
later i'm sitting there because you can
sit like in this outdoor area and i'm
watching the guy like walk up to each
customer and like you know go over like
what do you want from the board so some
like 1999 nissan sentra
roll slowly rolls up and he goes um he
goes which one do you want and the guy
must have said whatever he goes you're
lucky i'm in a good mood today because
this car ain't even worth washing it's a
piece of [ __ ] and then gives him his
tuck and then the guy's just sitting
there at the wheel like that
just going and i was like i kind of love
this guy so i was like wow this is
criminal this is a criminal
it's a bold business i wonder if now the
guys who robbed the money are involved
with the car wash it's the whole sting
operation coming out of the car wash wow
that's like a breaking bad type of deal
yeah it's coming out of the car wash wow
you're you're a local you never you
never witnessed
uh have i witnessed i don't think
remember the last time i saw a live and
active robbery there's been a lot of
places where i've said so what about
this what about that on staten island
and and you you you i think there's a
lot of new things that have popped up
that you're not privy to what's down
yeah i will tell you that my staten
island acumen yeah has dropped
significantly in the last deck
um because i don't frequent as many
spots anymore i used to but like it's a
little tough now because born and raised
and i already knew everybody already but
to go somewhere it's like yeah it's just
a little tough in the world
i get it
and i and i truly truly have a hole in
my heart about it like i miss it no like
i i um she got that checked out i know i
know it could be like an afib or
something dangerous but no no i because
every once in a while i do have to take
a lap somewhere yeah you know if i'm
visiting a relative or like i don't know
what and i'll drive down a thoroughfare
that i haven't been down in a while and
it is completely different change and
i'm like man
hey what's up if you want to see me on
the road go to chrisdcomedy.com
we have october 15th and 17th nashville
we've added a thursday show and a
saturday early show the other shows are
all but sold out october 23rd foxwoods
both shows almost sold out the first one
is sold out second one has limited
tickets left november 21st starting the
pre-sale is happening right now for
laugh boston
sorry let me do that again sorry hey if
you want to see me on the road go to
christycomedy.com october 15 to the 17th
nashville we've added a thursday show
and we've added a saturday show october
23rd foxwoods fox woods we've added a
a second show some seats to the second
show you have both shows there at
foxwoods october 23rd then october 29th
of course co-headlining with the babe
salvolcano in durham
november 21st at the wilbur theater in
boston we have just added a 5 p.m show
we've added a second show at the wilbur
the pre-sale is happening right now use
the promo code chaos on sale for
everybody tomorrow but the first uh uh
wilbur show at 8 p.m is almost sold out
we've added 5 p.m that's sunday november
21st thank you so much christy
comedy.com
i missed i miss being able to walk
around yeah not that i can't but but i
choose not to just so it's
so the easier on the garbage man in
front of my house the garbage man in
front of my house goes i i saw him i was
taking out the trash did i tell you this
what happened with the garbage man i
okay as of right now i can't tell so i i
i'm taking out the you know the trash at
6 30 in the morning whatever and i
noticed that it's 3 30 6 30 in the
morning
why are you going out at that time
that's when the garbage man come to take
out the garbage in front of me if you're
allowed i think i think you must be
allowed the night before
really
i thought you had to take it i mean if
you're up 6 30 doing doing stuff because
the kids anyway i guess i've been waking
up at like 5 30 on garbage money wow
that seems unreasonable by the city
because i thought you can't leave it out
because of the raccoons
well does it have covers with handles
yeah but i thought raccoons can get
right through that well i mean
no because raccoons are everywhere right
yes but i thought
a lot of them are on my neighborhood
okay but
what what where did you get this
information i thought you'd get a ticket
if you had your garbage out before i
thought you had like maybe an hour
before an hour you could be right but i
think that you're allowed a grace period
of the night before especially if it
comes at 5
email heybaypod gmail.com let us know
what your garbage my takeout routine
retired sanitation man i should ask him
yeah oh he's retired sanitation yeah so
he yeah there's a lot of questions i
have for him i mean he's been working
for 20 years since his retirement but he
also so he goes in and throws out the he
goes and runs no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no not in the senate
he's had like three jobs since he
retired from sanitation so so what i did
was i go out to the city not like right
not like organized so
i go out i go out to the to the he had
nothing to do with the robbery nothing
well we'll see if this holds up in court
uh do me a fun time favor could you just
rip the uh
cue rip that thing off there that thing
hanging
[Laughter]
sal what is the most staten island
moment you've ever lived i know it's a
heart oh god i'd have to
take a a gander for a minute for that
well let me i've seen i've seen i've
seen my fair share i mean i mean a lot
of stuff i mean yeah well but what i
would say well this is the stat moment
when i see with the garbage man when i
when i throw at the garbage in the
morning he goes um he left a garbage bag
in the pail i hate when that happens so
the garbage truck was going down the
street and i flagged him and i said hey
sir you forgot a bag he goes i'll make a
u-turn so the garbage they just make a
u-turn for no reason oh i thought you're
gonna he's gonna tell you i'll get it
next time no they make a u-turn and he
pops off the side you know like like
that thing like he pops off the rail
like he's in newsies just
off and he goes uh he goes you knew here
and i was like yeah he was like what's
your name i was like chris he goes i'm
joe i was like yeah i don't know why you
know i was i was like i'm just like is
that recycling am i i'm just trying to
get a thing you know scope of what it is
i don't know i said you know i've been
coming out here every day at 5 a.m you
know on garbage morning and and he says
um he goes yeah yeah yeah he goes listen
to me he goes i left that i left that in
the pail for you he goes because the
thing is is he goes you help me we'll
help you i hand to god he goes you help
me we'll help you he goes but throw the
bag in the back i said i can throw the
bag in the thing he goes go ahead do it
have fun so i throw the bag so i go i
throw the bag in the bag and he goes you
help me i'll help you so i'm assuming
that means i need to grease him i'm
assuming if i don't give him some cash
oh that can't be what that means what
else couldn't have inspectors telling
them they can't do nothing like that
he can't ask you it's a city job
but what did he feel about that he left
a bag what do you mean by that maybe to
be like you don't you don't help me out
you don't grease me a little bit with
some cash oh but you and i'm gonna leave
bags of garbage you went right to
greasing though what are the things it
could mean before grief you helped me i
mean what did you want to do before like
a felony what could it mean bring them i
mean maybe like um it's got to be
something
you let me know that i didn't take it
sorry about that or maybe man you helped
me put the bags in the right cans maybe
i didn't have a maybe i didn't have a i
was putting a garbage bag in a recycling
can or recycling bag in a garbage can
maybe that but he also had a neck tattoo
and his name was joe yeah so that kind
of feels like it's cash or some type of
bribery wow you help me i help you he
goes you help me i'll help you and then
i went out actually is it is it daylight
are you out in the dark with this it was
6 30 so the sun was just coming up wow i
mean nice guy was a very similar there's
a morning due morning oh yeah it was a
nice morning brisk nice nice first
morning and i went out there today to
you know help me to help him but i
didn't even see him there was a
different group of garbagemen i gotta
believe that garbage can be left the
night before you should look into it
lest you want to wake up every morning
at five oh
yeah it's a i'll try to do it i just
don't want i'm at the point now i don't
there's only about five or six houses on
my block so i don't want to upset the
neighbors you know what i mean well what
do they do did you see garbage pails out
the night before that's something you
could do scope peep the hood out see
what never even thought of it i never
thought of it because i wake up in a
panic on garbage morning saying i gotta
get garbage yeah before the truck comes
yeah because i always think the truck
and i've had a lot of garbage because i
just moved in i mean a lot of garbage
yeah yeah do you have one of those
things out front that you get like a big
big a big uh no i just celtic pale by
pale
and also chris is new to neighbors he's
an apartment kid yeah i've never had a
neighbor oh man like never real
neighbors like even going and saying
hello did you go over yet respecting the
neighbors no they've dropped us they've
dropped they we got an edible
arrangements we got a bath and body
works um we got interesting things we
got from one neighbor we got uh edible
arrangements love it bath and body works
very nice did they say their address
yeah they're addressing who we are who
the neighbors are so it's nice and then
we got one of them
gave us a gift card to go get our
portraits taken
that's what the neighbor got us to get
like a family portrait
it's a gift certificate to go get
portraits taken on some some film studio
some portrait studio on staten island
that's that's it's it's very very
thoughtful so it's also um what i didn't
know how to feel very presumptive
yeah like a portrait they're like i know
but you're all in the matching khakis
and white button downs and you'll have
no shoes all the neighbors from across
you all have no shoes on yeah right
you're all sitting indian style with
khakis and a white shirt i know that you
should do that yep john and meg from
can you do that
blow that [ __ ] up yep to a nice 24 by 36
put a nice gilded frame as soon as you
open the door to your house
right there you guys sears
sockless boom right there and everyone's
like in a cute pose or whatever yes when
he said have fun with it throw no
garbage did you go
yeah i did i literally i honestly when i
threw it i kind of got like chills i was
like this is so fun
how about this my grandfather used to
work on the garbage trucks he was 90 you
know he's been he's been dead a while
but he would have been in his late 90s
now
he's shot from heaven he
he if they get wi-fi god knows what's
going on up there with covet and
everything i don't know um but but he he
said to me he used to work he worked he
was a garbage man for 30 years as well
when he first started they didn't have
the crusher they would take garbage and
then pass it up to a guy standing on top
of the garbage truck and there was a
humongous fan in the garcia that would
slice the garbage in half and multiple
times a year men would fall through and
die yeah and get sliced in f and they
said we have to change it because if
literally the driver hits a pothole and
you fall back you're falling into a fan
that will slice you in half like it was
just it's like it's just samurai swords
have you heard of this uh i know there's
been a lot of accidents in and around
and surrounding garbage trucks
but not the cro but did your dad work at
the ones that were crushers or did they
have the blades he worked as a crusher
it was a crusher yeah uh
a couple of fun stories he used to take
me when when he has to work overnight
for the salting when there's gonna be
big storms oh nice like i remember one
or two times like when i was a kid
he let me come with him like wow he was
doing our neighborhood or maybe he
wasn't but he passed by you're right and
he was like you want to come with me and
i was like yeah and i bundled up got in
the car because there's two
uh two steering wheels oh my god i
didn't drive it because i was a kid but
i like made believe i drove it right but
uh yeah and i would like drive with him
through the night like salting and just
salting and it was probably like school
was closed it was like a special
occasion i mean highly leagues highly
well well not back then
yeah
do what you want now it's fine every you
know now you can't really have any fun
yeah you can't do that anymore now now
it'd be highly illegal to do that he
used to go to uh he he started off in
manhattan in the lower east side which
was a tough hood a lot of garbage to
navigate yeah it's that's like all these
enjoyments plus like 30 that was like 40
years ago so it was like not even as
nice as it was now right like that was
wasn't nice back then no it was like it
was not good it was like freaking uh
thunderdome down there yes yes yes yes
then he got transferred when they made a
brand new station on staten island
across from the mall standing on two wow
they they that wasn't always there they
just had uh so he transferred to there
when it was new right he loved that
because he was on the island and it was
like a country club because it's like
brand new they had their own gym in
there i used to go like visit him at
work i would pop in and be like oh is
sal here because he when he got off work
and then he was always in the gym he
like lived in the gym you and i need a
sitcom where we're garbage men
don't you think like that's the show for
us
you and i we're too like most people
feel like we are like we are we fit the
profiles yeah they're like oh
hey babe are the garbage men yeah
they're too sensitive garbagemen yeah
even if you look at the wikipedia the
salvo cano you know you know from
practical jokers was you know formerly a
garbage man you want to like
we'll write something up should we do a
thing where we're just garbagemen i'm
always looking for a vehicle maybe yeah
what do we do me and you are garbage men
tt jerry's our supervisor
[Laughter]
she's the sharp woman
wow i think garbage i think us being
garbage man is the way to go because
homeless pimp looks like and we model a
character after almost him because he
looks like what a garbage man should be
well he's very fashionable train no just
in the face and the beard not his
fashion his fashion is great yeah yeah
it's terrific terrific fashionable and
he's skinny now what do you want up in
lb's
when i go to eat with chris i just order
salad and then i don't eat when i'm
alone how many consecutive salads have
you eaten so you come down to to look
the way you look because you you look
you look uh thinner than you than you
were what is it 30 pounds probably 30.
are you [ __ ] me 30.
30 pounds
no it's crazy but he still drinks beer
two of the heaviest bowling balls
combined
why isn't it 16 pounds the heaviest
we're about to google it i don't know
yeah sorry bowling ball i want to tell
you something about bowling what's your
highest bowling score ever three go
no i don't think i've ever went bowling
without bumpers really i don't think
i've ever went bowling regularly once
i've never in my life once said we
should go bowling or like thought like a
bowling's a weekend activity and it's
kind of daunting on me now that i should
because i have little kids yeah which
nothing is more fun than like a cosmic
bowling and i've never even thought to
do it yeah we should do it you want to
go bowling
this place uh i don't bowl often maybe
once every few years on like some weird
occasion where someone's like let's just
do it but as a kid i did it what was the
highest ah i think i broke two once or
twice in my life but i'm not a good
bowler right like i could bowl an 80 or
130 or 160 so
i don't want to go balling do you have
to i i don't know if you have to ball
with my disks on intramural oh i'm not
putting my fingers in those holes right
now
oh you will not no what about a bowling
glove
does that exist did you just invent
something do they have a bowling glove
gloves i'm pretty sure really 16 pounds
is the heaviest ball by the way so two
three of the heaviest balls at 32 that's
a imagine just two bolts 16 pound
bowling balls just dropped off his body
and bounced right yeah that's how much
weight he's lost via salad consecutive
that's how much weight you carry around
like even if you just to lose 30 pounds
is monumental for your body because
think about granted it's dispersed all
over the body so it's not accurate
accurate but in a way it is i mean it's
in your body yeah 100 i've had yeah i
got bowling but i have bowling ball
scatter all over my body i got them all
right now i got a whole rack i'm a whole
rack of bowls right now i'm a yeah so
high quality food delivered right to
your door
you talking about butcher boxes you know
i am bro you know what because you know
what i was thinking about i was looking
at you before i said i'd love to put my
meat in his box yeah nine to eleven
pounds they'll give you that's what i'm
saying that's right you choose
everything like 100 grass-fed and
finished beef free-range organic chicken
humanely raised pork wild caught lobster
tails and wild caught alaskan salmon
sugar-free bacon yeah look and they're
giving new members two pounds of free
ground beef what club do you join where
you get two two free pounds of ground
i've been searching my whole life yeah
that gives me two pounds free ground
beef and i never found one till right
now there you go well the butcher box
all you gotta do is become a member
they're gonna literally they're gonna
take two pounds of ground beef and it's
gonna be at your door they're gonna
throw it off the side of your door you
sign up you choose a box you choose the
frequency you want it delivered they
offer five different kinds you can
choose your option you can customize the
box they ship it to you frozen at peak
freshness in a hundred percent
recyclable box it always ships free i
mean the list goes on and on about why
there's i mean a no-brainer no brainer
frequency for me is 24 7. i'd like a
non-stop conveyor belt of ground beef
coming into my face nine to 11 pounds
all the time this is your chance to
never have to shop for ground beef again
yeah butcher boxes giving new members
free ground beef for life sign up at
butcherbox.com
hey babe and get two pounds of ground
beef free in every order for the life of
your membership log on to butcherbox.com
hey babe to claim this deal boom
all right this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp if you are a nut bag out
there you really just having mental
health issues we all are as i am which
is coming from the two biggest nutties
the two biggest nuts in the world
right here i mean me and sal you want to
talk about huge nuts that's the balsamic
society written i am worried about
everything look at this i'm going to
switch it says anxiety tuesday better
help but better help
is helping me because the next time i
release a sweatshirt it's just going to
say tuesday because better help remove
the anxiety okay they'll assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist it's not
a crisis line it's not self-help it's
just professor professional counseling
yes done securely online you can start
communicating within 48 hours
services available for clients worldwide
yes log in anytime and send a message to
your counselor and get timely and
thoughtful responses back better help
want you to start living a happier life
today we want you to start living a
happier life today we don't want you to
be sad that's the last thing i wanted
you to be sad eating food in the parking
lot i want you to be happy i want you to
be happy and i want you to be alert i
want you out there helping out everybody
in the community and the way to do that
is go to betterhelp.com
hey babe that's
dot betterhelphelp.com slash hey babe
you're gonna get ten percent off your
first month okay ten percent of your
first month betterhelp.com hey babe
there is bowling gloves it looks like a
big j okarson special oh but
yeah but that means you still get these
in there the pinky my flesh ain't
touching in the innards of that ball not
gonna do that during cove 19. never 20
and 21. what when is the next time when
are you gonna feel safe going back to
bowling i mean you may never bowl again
what if the balls are found
to be what polio is now in order for me
to bowl again so you're talking so we're
talking about 60 years no i don't know
you want to go bowling on your 95th
i will i will do that i'll go bowling
with the machine where you roll it like
that arcade oh yeah yeah i want you guys
to guess what the salary is of a
professional bowler okay first of all
there's one bowler the only bowler
professional i know is pete weber jr
there's a he's a big wig bowler he's got
to be a multi-millionaire but any just
you talk about the average salary for
someone in the professional circuit yes
okay yes because i think i would imagine
it goes on how many lines do you play
i don't know the bowling season but i
would imagine it goes off prize money
golf structure or something like that
i'm going to say 250k
yeah my initial thought if you're gonna
be a profesh was you're breaking six
figures you have to be yeah and i was
gonna say 200.
so let's
so two so first of all you were right
that walter ray williams is the highest
paid one i said pete webber
williams same difference yeah yeah yeah
too many three three three three names
yeah he's worth 4.9 million dollars not
bad but he's like the tiger woods he's
the guy so who's the
what's your you ready for the average
forty two thousand dollars oh my god
forty two thousand dollars a year oh my
god that's the show you two are
professional bowlers that suck oh my god
well i'll tell you i'll tell you one
thing if i'm a professional bowler
how could you make it enough to be
professional you're signed in you're in
the league you're in the union you're in
the the the circuit right you are a
professional bowler it says on your card
right
but
you're scraping together 42. that's not
the best
salary for a especially for someone a
professional with a skill set like that
so you imagine that person a
professional bowler he's already
he or she has achieved
like the recognition of being so good
that they're allowed to be a
professional yet they go to a tournament
trembling because they don't know if
they'll make the most of them
right well imagine be like i gotta get
this [ __ ] strike and they live on the
road they live on the road and they're
all sponsored by beer company i bet you
a lot of them alcoholics are all
sponsored by like molson olsen
yeah what's it called isn't it called
molson i feel like a lot of a lot of
bowlers where like just people that
already used to wear slacks as just a
matter of 100 it's a matter of course i
feel like if you're a bowler you've been
rocking pleats since you're a child
since you're a child you know and it's
just a transition it's just like i'm
going to change my shirt but the pants
are going to stay the same and i'm going
to go hard in the lanes i honestly
admire though a bowler like that because
if you're making 42k a year to be a pro
you're doing it for the love of the game
you love bowling you grew up in a
bowling alley you probably have divorced
parents or one of them's in prison yeah
right you're not going to become a
professional bowler if you're coming
from one of the family the father had to
go to prison at some point am i wrong
why else are you in a bowling alley all
day every day that's not something
somebody you got a healthy family yeah
if you're a professional bowler out
there email they babypod gmail.com tell
us what your father did to get in prison
tell us what your daily life is you're a
team tell us how you put yourself
together and all that stuff yeah you
know what i mean i mean the side view of
the hairs it you guys can't see it from
my ankle but the way it curls up is it's
phenomenal it's uh yeah it's just a
different i don't want you to have short
hair anymore
on now no but it's fine it's matted down
i want you guys to take a guess when
bowling was invented
i'm going to attack
it
as we know it and it's first form
inception i'm going to say in england in
the 1200s or maybe king henry viii 1500s
i want to say it's english because i'm
thinking lawn bowling yeah i am thinking
back in the day like some type of
entertainment or sport like that is very
uh
rudimentary so i'm i'm going to think uh
yeah mid mid mid middle ages
5000 bc 5000 bc egyptian egyptians wow
kidding me what were they rolling
people's heads 1000 bc were they rolling
people's heads off pyramids
it doesn't say what the objects were but
they had
the group of objects and
i didn't even know they had slacks back
then
[Laughter]
they take the mummies apart they're just
slacks
do me a favor throw a pleat in that
sarcophagus yeah
my god
do you ever think someone who's a bowler
on the road all the time sponsored by
beer companies maybe not in a great way
maybe as a tumultuous relationship he
comes home and he hears [ __ ] from his
wife or their husband and do you ever
think someone who is a professional
bowler heard from their paw now oh spare
me
and then and then they're like don't do
that to me yeah i don't want to be what
do you want to do strike me
yeah don't do that don't make a mockery
i'm a professional
[Laughter]
and frame someone else
all the words from the words i imagine
it's like eastbound and down
yeah same thing same thing it'd be fun
that your dad's like a professional
bowler when he gets made he just starts
bowling [ __ ] down the hallway
your brothers and sisters and your mom
clean the room oh you don't want to just
bowl
watch it watch what your ps5 can do
oh my god that would stink yeah that's
it's interesting it's very very
interesting that these sports like that
like like lacrosse you know lacrosse and
you can uh pronounce lacroix
you're right you're right and i'm sorry
about that it's the lacrosse i bear i
always say it wrong
so so
lacroix
was invented by the native americans
back in the day but did you know that
they would play
the winner not the loser the winner
would be sacrificed to the gods and they
would play the game after you lost the
winners
who were dead would get beheaded and
then loser and team would play with
their heads like use use their heads to
some form of lacrosse game amongst
themselves because it was an honor
to win
and then be beheaded because your body
and soul was given to the gods and you
were entered into you know whatever
kingdom you believed in that time as the
winner of the lacrosse game is this
headless lacrosse horseman how accurate
is that
eminent but
almost like you ever get beheaded in
about
yeah but that's crazy because like so
you're saying they're like
hoping to die they
i don't think death i think death back
in parts of history like that wasn't as
feared because you life was like
yeah and it was like you have
everybody's got malaria there's you have
diarrhea all day every day and they're
spiritual as well so they're not they're
assuming maybe there's something beyond
that well i think they had to do that
because back in the day i mean if
literally everywhere you looked everyone
was literally dying of of infections
fevers and diarrhea you would make the
afterlife some type of gift because
you're like it's got to get better so
they would convince themselves like hey
life is better life your life begins
after death so these people would gladly
get beheaded because they're like what
else am i going to do get eaten by a
panther so now i'm picturing a guy
he
lives in uh you know some fashion tl
monk two
uh uh uh
tito coleman is where he lives
uh uh what's it called not timbuktu tito
come
the guy phil the indian guy named phil
this panthers
pant is roaming the street at
intersections
militant group not the group no just
talking about actual jungle cheetahs
there's cheetahs roaming the street like
if you want to get a genius that's
getting fined there's cheetahs and
panthers yeah wow this wild animal fowl
anything you want
disease infested foul you got malaria
maybe on a foot or two
you got lepers you got leopards you got
everything right you're looking at
people people are coming through
they're pillaging all this stuff it's
terrible it's horrifying you're 19 your
life expectancy is like four more years
nobody's vaccinated two kids right
and this guy is like
i just gotta get better all across
i just gotta get better at lacrosse and
then i will enter the torn and they will
slaughter me
and i will be on to greener pastures yes
you imagine like looking every which way
and everything everything is just
terrible and your out is to just buck up
and get a little better at la crosse yes
and then you have an out of this world i
don't know i mean i don't understand now
we live in a world where you you eat so
much and eat so good that you literally
get your feet cut off that's the world
we live in now is the goal is is to
literally go into heaven footless
because the amount of cake you ate so
that's
that's right so depend which world do
you want to live in some people might
pick the old world
the old world is severely depressing me
right now yes
well because because
when you watch a movie
like everything about doom and gloom
like when you watch a movie and they
romanticize shout out to all you guys
who came before us and that because
we're we're here because of you
yeah everyone that came before us i i
mean what else can we do but to give you
all the presents
by the way shout out panthers shout out
shout out chief shout out buccaneer
shout out tom brady shout out tom brady
shout out sean brady and speaking of
indians i guess the kansas city jeeps
yeah you gotta mention
this if i didn't mention patrick holmes
because he is a hell of a player and the
tampa bay bucks won that whole thing in
their home stadium yeah while he was the
oldest player in the nfl yes and as as
my aunt val used to call called the
tampa bay buccaneers at tampa bay and
ears wow that's your question i didn't
like to use to call me christophe
wow how about this ready ready for this
text i got yesterday from my mom i was
dying laughing my mom because she's
being dead serious my mom goes
she goes chris please call me it's
urgent i meant to comment on liz's
flowers and instead of commenting
beautiful i wrote beautiful how do i
delete
how do you even have beauty in your
phone that's what i said i said how did
you even have beautiful the phone she
goes just please tell me how to how to
delete then i didn't respond she goes
did delilah have swimming this week
um
babe we talk about this a lot yeah
listen two out of three men are gonna
suffer from male pattern baldness
there's three men in the room right now
which ones which two of us are going to
get male pattern baldness well it's a
guarantee no matter what it is not say
another thing i've been using a comb
nowadays when my hair got a little
longer okay and i tell you when i'm done
doing that comb and i look on it a lot
of my hair is on that comb i gotta you
want do you want something to help that
or do you not that's why i brought it up
keeps.com that's what it is peeps.com is
gonna help you with that because help me
keep what i have you can help you keep
what you stop
freeze stop in the name of keeps yeah
before you lose your hair stop keeps
time
yeah
keeps time
officers simple stress-free waiting keep
your hair convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medications delivered
straight to your door every three months
you don't have to leave your home low
cost treatments start at just ten
dollars a month keeps offers generic
versions discrete packaging improvement
results keeps has more five star reviews
than any of its competitors prevention
is key dreams can take four to six
months to see results so act fast act
fast whoop act fast act fast if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to
keps.com hey hey babe that's only one
hey babe slash hey babe to receive your
first month of treatment for all free
that's k-e-e-p-s dot com slash hey babe
to get your first month free k-e-e-p-s
dot com
slash hey babe
imagine like we'd like to make good
just watching the executives in the
office just watch that bomb for them
you know what i did talk to me because i
don't have cable no more i don't know i
actually don't have cable anymore you
cut the cord i cut the cord with cable i
ain't got cable no more i ain't got the
cable no more which is double negative
which would mean i would have cable but
i don't have cable i don't have cable
anymore well i i have cable and
streaming services and i've had enough
yeah i was gonna say it's getting
redundant yeah i want one i want one
place that i can go that's going to give
me enough of what i need unfortunately
you have cable you have you said you
have cable and you have all these other
streaming services i got two words for
you stupid [ __ ] right unfortunately
and i got one word for you
phylum p-h-i-l-o yes philo why do i add
up what i'm paying now i i i i'm
ballparking but i end up paying like 2-3
million dollars a month for cable easy
yeah dude easy
it's unbelievable it's unbelievable how
when i come in i'm like look at this
money pit from all the cable courts you
have and i'll tell you another thing
philo as they're telling us and i'm
gonna believe him was created by tv
lovers for tv lovers yes but honestly
it's 25 bucks a month which and here's
what you get
60 premium television
massive on-demand library of top-tier
beloved shows and movies you can watch
anytime unlimited dvr which other ones
don't have the best and biggest in the
industry uh you could save shows up to
like a year which is crazy nobody else
can you save it for like two weeks
they're like okay you gotta delete it
this is up two years i walk around with
anxiety about my dvr space running out
you don't have to worry about the filo
and you can stream it to three devices
at the same time and filo was super easy
to set up with no hassles and no
contracts which i love no contracts is
big uh uh i asked my friends at philo if
i could offer you guys a special deal
and guess what they said of course they
said yes at first they did say no yeah
because of some of the recent actions of
us on the bay podcast then they came
around and they said yes let's just do
it let's just get 25 off your first two
months go to philo philo dot com
dot sorry sorry filo dot tv
slash hey babe that's filo dot tv
slash hey baby this is a new one and i
and i'm liking it i'm liking it i like
it no seriously we we actually they gave
us uh free subscription subscriptions
and i i truly have canceled everything
else now it's filo dot tv slash hey babe
that's what i didn't i didn't even get
that discount they just gave it to us
for free and i literally i am i'm philo
i'm i'm a i'm a phylomaniac you're a
beautiful [ __ ] christian speaking to
throwback people you ever just think
about trying to survive with dinosaurs
running around no you can't you can't
what is your dinosaur strategy no you
can't oh we did someone did
we outlived them
no but did somebody get in the brush
long enough
no i don't know we weren't around
oh that's just uh how uh history does
that they put cavemen
like with kind of we associate cavemen
with dinosaurs
carpets yeah when they show the
exhibition okay
no yeah did i just say something crazy
we're in the dinosaurs hundreds and
hundreds
but couldn't have a dinosaur snuck
around and chilled that's what i'm
saying because sharks were around sharks
have been around
every single dinosaur die in the ice age
i don't know they're saying that they
can bring dinosaurs back now like
jurassic park stuff is coming true
they're saying actively now scientists
can which makes you believe that they
have already it makes you believe that
they have brought dinosaurs back we read
an article that they're spending 15
million to bring back woolly mammoths
like really fully bring them woolly
mammoths are elephants with haircuts
they're spending 15 million yeah to
bring them back yeah who's in charge of
that some psychotic who stood before a
board and was like guys hear me out
wooly mammoths haven't been around for a
while yeah my plan despite everything
else going on in this world is to race
15 mil yeah and i'm just going to have
him start and what in captivity yeah i
well me and chris went down this rabbit
hole and we think they're going to start
zoos of extinct animals that's what we
think we think the real dress apart
[ __ ] though that's going to happen i
would go to that zoo i think i'm not i
don't know but i think my daughters will
see a real
live dinosaur in front of them for real
in a zoo as some type of wild attraction
do you you're saying that they could
it would be essentially the same thing
because the dna would be the same yes
yes yes because they're saying that they
can just in jurassic park they would
take the dna from you know honey or
something hold hold
they lived at a very different time and
the way they thrived and grew and ate
and and and the way they procreated and
the way they roamed
couldn't be recreated now
so isn't it cruel to just bring back a
t-rex just just for the fun of it of
course but i mean that doesn't i mean
humans don't i mean yeah they don't care
they're gonna clone us right
that's the thing is anything that i read
on the news on vice or i'm like it
happened 20 years ago then then the
dinosaurs have been around for 20 years
are we gonna be in a position where
instead of the woolly mammoth the guy's
gonna be like sinatra
yeah let's talk about it because yeah
what's the number to bring that guy back
you know what i mean 100 and then all of
a sudden like delilah like at age 40 is
going to go see a frank sinatra 100 dude
ted williams his head and body is frozen
right now cryogenics you could bring him
back and have him play for the red sox
yeah he is cryogenically frozen he's
questions
i heard that too yeah imagine if they
could license your dna
they probably can who's going to be in
charge of your socials and dna when you
die wow oh yeah good point i want
somebody really fun to be in charge of
my socials in dna i want somebody really
fun making it like charlie sheen just
making decisions for me behind the
scenes
i'm trying to think who would be yeah
yeah who would be just fun
fun per because yeah because like we've
said we said before we were talking
before like somebody you know when
people die somebody runs their socials
like if
legacy social yeah like would you tweet
in their voice or would you start
putting your opinions out there not
mimicking the dead voice would you just
say if they if they had a big account
well why would i tweet in their voice
they're not everyone knows they're not
alive any longer right so
what am i trying to do let's let me
let's say let's say let's say you know
let's say somebody really a famous
really famous friend of yours died
okay let's say i'm giving you a
hypothetical i'm giving you hypothetical
yeah let's say a really famous friend of
yours died right they die they say their
last wishes you take and they give you
the password they say take it yeah tweet
at my bf and then they croak and you say
fine yeah and a couple years ago and
then i'm talking about a big account
like what mil let's say the rock let's
say it's the rock okay let's say it's
dwayne the rock johnson says i need
something a friend of mine i need sound
volcano to literally run my social media
i need him to run my social media let's
say 10 years ago you're doing what
you're doing you're doing it uh what do
you you know but you're still on the
road you're out there do you at some one
point say
you know you the rock you smell what the
rock is cooking you know i've been dead
10 years but i'm still here the people's
elbow
goobies i'll be on my goobies at timonia
maryland
my good friend salva khanna will be at
maguis maryland
out to 25 mil on twitter you think you
could yeah maybe all right
i might do 10 for him one for me yeah
yeah yeah i mean if you had to freaky
fry with anybody who would you do it
freaky friday with anybody just yeah
that's dead or alive or they have to be
alive freaking fantastic questions i
think a lot because if it's dead or
alive if it's any person in ever it's
not even i don't even have to use a
brain cell to say i will be whitney
houston i'll trade i'll be whitney
houston immediately and she could be me
but i want to be whitney you should i'm
talking about knowing everything about
what eastern i want to be when you used
to um one because you want to be able to
sing like that because bobby brown gives
it to you nice
the ladder combo the ladder um
so so if i if i had to freaky friday
with anybody dead or a lot uh just alive
right now somebody who i would love to
switch positions with i'd want to be
if i could be anybody i'd say the person
i'd want to be the most
right now
can be anyone in the world
would be um um um um ariana grande
i can't i get that yeah i get that i'd
be honest young burgeoning career
basically runs the world right now from
a young age
uh you basically could probably just do
whatever you wanted to do yeah and then
you'd also be able to sing really great
that's what it is part of you really
wants to sing like a really great female
powerhouse i'm the guy when i hear a
song that i really like i imagine myself
being that person singing that song on
stage yeah for those reasons i've also
daydreamed about switching with justin
timberlake justin i feel like he has a
terrific tenor of his voice and i
he's someone who's like can sing and
dance and at the same time which i
always as a as a comet as anywhere i
think anyone would wish they could sing
right you know but then again no because
then i would want to be a musician too
maybe as someone who's really crazy at
the piano or something like that right
but i i gotta go derek cheetah derek
cheetah was was one i had in my head i
just think he's got a very celebrated
illustrious career he's connected to new
york
he is still around my age
uh he basically also writes his own
ticket he's done with the hard work now
he's probably just going to coast done
uh he's respected everywhere worldwide
yes i think cheetah
i also might want to be cindy crawford
interesting she's hot yeah i just think
that she's also just been
doing
her thing for a real long time she's
still wonderful yeah she's she's just i
mean just a real good longevity you know
what i'd also like to be flavor flav
yeah just fun everybody loves him he
lights up a room he lights up a room
lights up a room has a has a real good
time yeah mark anthony's another one i'd
like to be mark anthony mark anthony i
mean great you know you know
jayla's your ex-wife you know like
you're you're a beautiful singer you
know my girl current girlfriend had an
opportunity to go on a date with mark
anthony she said no
why is that
she just said no and i kind of honestly
being in a relationship but i know i'm a
little bit like i don't know what kind
of decisions you make right i don't know
if we can get to the next step i may go
on a date with mark anthony you said no
to mark anthony and you thought that was
good for your life how right how did you
so so now you you want me to marry you
and you're making decisions like like
saying no to mark anthony he's got a
clothing line in department stores
jayla's his ex-wife i understand yeah
and he can sing in spanish and english
and you and she said no no it was a
little history i think he even acts
isn't he like an suv or something 100
percent he is she told her remember we
were in bed she said to him i got up and
i had my
head in my hands and she's like i know i
shouldn't have told you that like you
know of course you get jealous i said no
no it's not about that it's about it's
about the woman i'm next to and the kind
of decision she makes and how i pass
that on what kind of decisions what is
who is my daughter looking up to right
who my daughter's looking up to if she
literally is looking mark anthony eisen
saying no
you haven't me mark anthony are you
going to apologize on her behalf 1 000
yeah i have a goal in life and i've just
really that's why i started this podcast
i want somebody to get this to mark
anthony to see this very i've been doing
40 episodes
for this moment if you're listening
and we know that you are uh hit us up
sound off in the comments mark anthony
mark anthony sound off and uh um
do you think mark anthony gets turned
down a lot i can't imagine he does right
and so maybe i guess in some ways that's
a power move
but it's a little bit like what are we
doing here so uh she just was not
interested so somehow so
somehow a member of her extended family
knows a a a musician in his band and he
was invited to they you know he went to
a show and then you know family and
friends of course in the backstage area
whatever msg wherever they were and
they were in the same room and he goes
hey you know introduced talking or
whatever we weren't dating at the time
and
um be your hero baby
is that his song
i thought it was aerosmith
no that's there that's foo fighters
there goes my hero no maybe i'm wrong
oh i might be uh maybe that's why no no
i i might be the guy with the sun
uh very famous guy glacier
yes enrique iglesias was the hot [ __ ]
when i was little my grandmother formed
over him she had the eight tracks she
had the eight tracks he had a son he
also sang a hero that's who sang heroes
that's why he sings big songs big songs
and i know it's like i i definitely know
mark anthony songs yeah so we know mark
so so i but would you guys be able to
date a celebrity i kind of get where
she's coming from
now but i'm not dana i'm showing you
just a little hanky-panky like just for
the story say you have sex with mark
anthony like i'd like to say that but
this is my girlfriend she had sex with
mark anthony like you know like come on
think about mock anthony though he's
always got to navigate being like i
wonder if this person is just gonna have
sex with me and leave and just say i
just had sex with mark anthony for the
fun of it
john mayer there was a story john may
this was public john mayer told the
story once i was in i was like well
that's interesting he said there was a
thing going around amongst women that
they were like all like in like it was a
lot of women like thousands of women
around this they would go back to john
mayer's apartment and not have sex with
them
no i've done that not have sex with him
how hard is that but they would go
when i held out but not and then like do
like this whole like it was this whole
thing where they would like they were
like
getting off on like leading john mayron
and not having sex with them but i was
like but john mayer probably just went
down to the bar and just got another
woman immediately right like it's john
mayer so there was a
it was like a conglomerate of females
that were trolling him he was saying it
on like a podcast interview like this
thing where it was like i noticed it
kept happening like all these times in a
row i was like what the hell is going on
he said and then one of the women
told him yeah there's like a bunch of us
going around like
purposely
tracking you getting on day two getting
to your apartment and not having sex
then laughing about it at another club
i'm like the joke's on you [ __ ] you
could have sex with john
and instead what you're gonna have sex
with me the pimp
it's a real long way to go and a lot of
effort to put in to just hit a group
chat with an lol yeah well i'm like yeah
that's that's hilarious guys like what
it's like john mayer q anon yeah it's so
dumb
yeah uh i googled can a normal person
date a celebrity and they said gotten
one and they said as long as you're
willing to be publicly scrutinized and
live on somebody else's production
schedule
it's true yeah it's not easy it ain't
easy it's not it's not easy you know i
mean i think i think okay
i think um yeah but i mean you know mark
anthony is just
that's a tough one for me to swallow but
we swallow i mean and if you listen to
mark i absolutely would have swallowed
um and still can whatever you want take
that as you wish
oh that was pimpy fell over the
equipment in the background
um
babe we got a show in like five minutes
here at the lyric baltimore in baltimore
the show starts at seven it's six almost
6 30. yeah so i'm gonna eat beef how
many before the show which you think is
insane i don't know before show but
since we're coey's
um maybe it's like a half's not bad but
when you're out there for an hour an
hour or whatever and you and you're like
oh i feel so tired because i ate right
before i went out so pimp is gonna film
this what are we gonna do we're gonna go
out i'll do 30 you do 30 and then we're
going to come out and just should we do
this should we ask somebody to bring
this couch out and just sit down
should we do a hey vape from the couch
what are we going to do we're going to
do questions and answers with the crowd
what are we going to do yeah we'll go
out there and we'll fool around just
fall in love like elven bishop did you
don't know the reference but some of our
listeners do no i do
i i don't know bishop uh elvis costello
maybe possibly a one-hit wonder must
have been through
about a million girls
i love a man i leave them alone
i wouldn't care how much they cried no
sir
their tears left me cold as a stone
but then i fooled around and fell in
love
i fooled around and fell in love
yes i did
i fooled around and felt you in love you
know what
no
hmm this has been great it's a great one
this has been hey babe um you can catch
me on the road christy comedy.com uh we
just put salt lake city on sale november
fifth and six wise guys salt lake city
the second show at the wilbur theater
has been added november 21st at 5 00 p.m
and uh my lovely fans of boston and
check the schedule you got zlatan's
nashville foxwoods and the that's where
i was going to durham october 29th me
and sally babes co-headlining if you're
missing the lyric if you missed the
lyric baltimore i'm sorry do not miss
durham do not miss it
anything for you
my dates are about to drop soon hold
tight i got a lot of damage drop it soon
a lot of dates they're dropping soon
folks mark anthony if you're listening
i'm i'm single
don't run away from your feelings
[Music]